well it's been a couple days now but
liberals are still in full hysteria and
panic over the thought that they might
lose their monopoly on speech in this
country since elon musk has bought
twitter army dylan has thought a lot
about this how to fix twitter's free
speech problem she is one of this
country's leading civil rights attorney
ceo of the center for american liberty
and a frequent guest here hermie dylan
thanks for coming on
so
so this is a it's actually if you get
into the details pretty complicated how
exactly do you fix twitter's free speech
problem
well first elon musk has in its hands
one of the most important perhaps the
most important free speech vehicles in
the world right now and so he has an
opportunity to change the discourse in
this country for the better and i think
there are a few simple things you can do
first of all you got to move twitter out
of san francisco and out of california
all together one of the big problems in
these big tech companies has been how
they are overwhelmingly left-wing and
that is what you see in the bias in how
these companies moderate speech and
content so if he moves it to florida to
texas to frankly any place in america
outside california i think that would be
a huge improvement
i've seen calls to fire employees i
wouldn't do that i think that's you know
extreme and also has liability issues
but i think he could ask people to
reapply for the position they want in
the company and then see if they're
willing to go along with some of these
new policies that i'm talking about i
think one of the important things that
elon musk needs to do is let back on to
twitter people who have been banned and
there are a lot of people including
clients of my firm uh rogan o'hanley is
currently suing twitter we also
represent some memes meisters like carpe
dangtam
and a megan murphy a feminist a radical
canadian feminist who was kicked off of
twitter for so-called misgendering all
of these people i think bringing them
back on would actually increase
popularity and uh traffic on twitter
which is what a business should want and
i think you know just going back to
something very simple that we learn as
children to be honest and transparent
that has been tremendously lacking in
twitter twitter has lied about how it
has put its finger on the scale about
election interference until after the
fact twitter is not transparent about
its policies its algorithms twitter is
not transparent about uh how people are
removed from the platform and twitter is
not transparent frankly about who its
users are i think elon musk has talked
about removing the bots from twitter i
think that would tremendously improve
the user experience so if he's like
there are a lot of complicated issues
here tucker and i'm sure he's getting
advice from all over the place and of
course i'm suing twitter so uh you know
ta that is a certainly a factor in what
uh what i have to say here but i think
if he wants to make a fresh start of
this amazing company with tremendous
value and potential for free speech he
can do all of these things and the final
thing i would say is
continue to strike that blow for free
speech that he's been doing on twitter
for the last few days united states
government is coming for elon musk
they're coming with today's announcement
of this disinformation
panel that they're going to have to
examine so-called disinformation
governance
panel um that is really the government
trying to impose the censorship that
elon musk is saying is no longer going
to going to exist on twitter so yeah i
think we all need to stand together for
that and have open and fresh
conversations i'm looking forward to
being on twitter for many years
hopefully with the fresh leadership the
panel you talked about is our lead for
tomorrow's show really one of the most
brazen assaults in the first amendment
in this century so uh quite amazing
armytalen thank you for that
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight